[Musique]
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé que
quelqu'un vous disent oh mais tu fais ça
aussi t'es pas juste ce métier là ou
bien si tu choisi cette voie tu pourras
pas faire ça aussi attention je suis sûr
que tout le monde dans la salle s'est
déjà plaint d'être dans un monde trop
catégoriser avec en général de polarité
binaire les filles les garçons les
sciences la littérature le corps
l'esprit mais est ce que vous vous êtes
déjà demandé d'où est ce que ça vient et
jusqu'à quel point cela impacte nos
choix une représentation personnellement
j'ai beaucoup le doit à la première
question le à mais tu fais ça aussi
parce que j'ai une double casquette je
suis docteur en neurosciences et
sexologue est dans ma vie j'ai été de
nombreuses fois confronté à cette
catégorisation binaire une des choses
qui m'a le plus marqué c'est est en
classe de seconde ou nous a demandé de
choisir entre scientifiques et
littéraires mois jusqu'à présent j'avais
été curieuse de tout jouer tout savoir
tout apprendre puis ladakh où fallait
choisir
mais je me suis partie de quelque chose
de très étrange c'est que les filières
scientifiques et techniques étaient
majoritairement associés aux garçons et
les filles elles allaient
majoritairement littéraire moi j'aimais
les deux pour moi ça avait un vrai
déchirement de choisir comme on peut pas
faire les deux j'ai pris s scientifique
parce que ce sens et m'ouvrir le plus de
voix et pour compenser ce choix imposé
je dévore des livres de philosophie de
psychologie de fraude
je suis fasciné par l'humain très vite
je sais que je veux faire des
neurosciences alors après mon bac je
vais en fac de biologie mais en fait je
suis très rapidement déçu parce que tous
les aspects de commissions de
comportements ne sont quasiment pas
abordé mais je veux plus avoir à choisir
entre l'étude de la matière vivante ou
bien la compréhension la psyché
n alors je décide d'entamer un double
cursus de biologie et de psychologie
pour l'anecdote j'ai un des professeurs
qui la prend au cours d'un rendez vous
il sursaute sur sa chaise non mais c'est
pas possible ça se fait pas on fait soit
de la biologie soit la psychologie si
j'avais su je voudrais pas accepter dans
mon programme
j'essaie de me défendre j'essaye
d'argumenter je vois que ça sert à rien
il est focalisée dans la vision dont on
fait soit ça soit ça je finis mon master
je pars faire ma thèse de neuroscience
cognitive en allemagne et comme je suis
très têtue et que je veux vraiment faire
de la biologie et la psychologie je
travaille sur la récupération des
souvenirs en abordant des thèmes de
psychologie cognitive et en utilisant
des techniques de biologie fondamentale
néanmoins après toutes ces années de
recherche
je me rends compte qu'il me manque
quelque chose
j'ai perdu quelque chose en route
quelque chose de fondamental il me
manque de l'humain de l'incarner alors
je vais chercher une discipline à
laquelle je pourrais relier toutes ses
connaissances en neurosciences et j'en
arrive à la sexologie et je peux enfin
en reliant ces deux disciplines prendre
l'humain dans son entier avec son corps
et son esprit et sa culture comme un
tout cohérent et je peux du coup enfin
chercher à comprendre pourquoi on est
arrivé à cette dissociation pourquoi
j'ai dû passer par ce double cursus
entre parenthèses j'ai aussi pu
apprécier l'ampleur de l'ironie
d'appeler les sons humaines et sociales
pour les filles des sciences molles et
les sciences techniques pour les garçons
les sciences dures donc
[Musique]
d'où cette pensée elle vient d'où elle
vient du dualisme de platon platon ce
philosophe grec postule que notre corps
et notre âme sont séparables que lorsque
nous mourrons notre corps va rester et
se décomposait sur terre mais notre âme
elle va s'envoler cela va poser les
bases pour la construction de nos
civilisations occidentales avec la rome
antique mais aussi et surtout avec les
trois grandes religions monothéistes et
on va voir comment dès la genèse ce
dualisme du corps et de l'esprit va
s'incarner dans l'essex avec le mythe
déjà de la création d'adam et eve
je vous rappelle que adam il est créé à
l'image de dieu il est de nature divine
mais eve elle elle est issue de sa cote
déjà lé matériel
ainsi on va avoir deux grands
théologiens qui vont utiliser ce mythe
pour expliquer que la femme elle n'est
pas exactement l'image de dieu au même
titre que l'homme et conclure qu'elle ne
pourra pas avoir de salut ou de
sublimation
et si elle en a un c'est que au travers
le service de son époux c'est aussi
intéressant de noter que saint-augustin
il va encore étendre ce dualisme du
corps et de l'esprit
jusqu'à sa conception même de l'amour il
va opposer le caritas l'amour des
sentiments l'amour chaste pieux
idéalement tourner vers dieu
le bonne amour à la cupidité as l'amour
charnel l'amour qui passe par le corps
l'amour qui est sale et péché ville si
on y réfléchit bien on est encore
aujourd'hui un petit peu dans ce genre
de conception ensuite on va avoir mon
préféré
je vous présente tertullien peu connu
néanmoins auteur triologie un très très
prolifique il a consacré de très très
nombreux ouvrages à nous maudire nous
les femmes ils nous détestent
puisque c'est une femme qui a mangé le
fruit défendu
c'est à cause d'elle à cause de nous que
l'humanité toute entière souffre ainsi
il a exhorté les femmes à se couvrir à
ne pas se farder à ne pas être coquette
à ne pas rappeler tout ce qui a trait à
notre sexualité
je vais en profiter pour faire un petit
aparté mes amis et collègues féministe
j'aimerais vous faire part d'une
réflexion parce que je m'interroge
beaucoup actuellement j'entends
énormément autour de moi l'expression
suivante il faut désexualisé le corps de
la femme moi cette expression me gêne un
petit peu parce que comme vous le voyez
ici
cette pensée est fondamentalement
misogyne mode habitude j'utilise plutôt
le terme de des objectifs y est pour que
notre corps ne soit plus justement un
objet de procréation ou un objet de
valorisation d'un ego masculin mais au
contraire je pense qu'il faut absolument
qu'on continue à se battre pour
permettre aux femmes qui le veulent je
dis bien qu'ils le veulent s'agit pas de
leur imposer
il faut qu'on continue de permettre aux
femmes qui le veulent d'avoir la
possibilité de se réapproprier cette
sexualisation de nos corps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et donc on va arriver à l'apogée de la
pensée chrétienne avec l'inquisition ou
les sorcières voix de brûler et
exactement au même moment les
civilisations orientales qui n'ont pas
un dualisme aussi marqué que nous à
certains endroits du monde
ils vont construire des temples qui
ressemble à ça c'est quand même plus
sympa quand même pas vous moi je préfère
là bas mais bon nous en occident on a
continué comme ça avec ce dualisme et on
va arriver justement à descartes
ce philosophe va en tant que bons
dualiste va aussi penser que notre âme
et notre corps sont séparables que notre
corps est une machine biologique qu'une
dame va rentrer et animé et qu'encore
une fois un autre morne tram va
s'envoler
sauf que les neurosciences ont montré
que cette vision cette pensée est
complètement fausse au début des années
justement un neuroscientifique appelé
damasio va publier un livre qu'il va
appeler l'erreur de descartes et dans ce
livre il va rassembler toutes les
preuves scientifiques qui montrent que
toutes ces qualités spirituelles comme
le raisonnement la pensée la logique la
morale ne sont que des purs produits de
notre cerveau pour preuve en 1848 un
homme qui s'appelle phinéas kate va être
victime d'un terrible accident
il va recevoir une barre de fer qui va
lui transpercer la tête comme ceci et
contre toute attente phinéas gage survie
à cet accident
il a juste perdu un bout de son cortex
préfrontal mais à première vue il va
bien sauf que sauf que toutes ses
facultés supérieures
son raisonnement sa logique sa morale sa
pudeur vont être profondément affectés
ainsi ses facultés qu'on pensait être
divine est immortel en fait elles sont
dans notre cerveau donc dans notre corps
matériel en neurosciences on considère
que ce dualisme est caduque
le corps n'est pas séparable de l'esprit
sauf que sauf que ses pensées dualiste
et genre et ses représentations dualiste
et genre et elle affecte encore nos
choix aujourd'hui par exemple en tant
que thérapeute
j'ai pu constater à quel point les
hommes ne vont que trop peu chez le psy
vous savez le nom mais moi ça va je suis
forcée bien j'ai pas besoin d'un psy
c'est bien normal qu'ils pensent comme
ça dans notre culture on leur explique
quoi on leur explique que leur essence à
eux elle est spirituelle
tomczyk mans ils se disent qu'ils
doivent pas avoir de problème
et s'ils ont un souci qui plus est c'est
ce souci est d'ordre sexuel ils se
disent que c'est forcément physiologique
sauf que voici les résultats d'une étude
qui montre que pour les hommes de moins
de 40 ans les troubles de l'érection
sont dus à 15% par des troubles
organiques mais à 85% par des causes
psychogène psychogène ça veut dire le
stress l'angoissé de la performance bord
de la dépression
d'ailleurs à ce sujet puisqu'il se
prennent moins en charge voire pas du
tout
les suicides sont trois à quatre fois
plus nombreux chez les hommes dépressifs
que chez les femmes dépressives et oui
messieurs les stéréotypes du patriarcat
vous tue vous aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce dualisme il a aussi des
conséquences tragiques pour nous les
femmes nord plus de crises cardiaques
que les hommes en fait les symptômes
sont un peu différent pour les familles
vont plus passer par des essoufflements
ou des maux de tête abrupte et jusqu'à
très récemment les médecins pensaient
qu'il s'agissait de troubles
psychosomatiques est renvoyée parfois
les femmes chez elle avec le mauvais
diagnostic
ajoutez à cela que certaines études
rapportent que des fois ce sont les
femmes elles mêmes qui pose ce faux
diagnostic
elles pensent qu'elles ont mal à la tête
que ça des psychologies qu'elles sont
stressés alors qu'en fait elles sont en
train de faire une crise cardiaque
et comme une femme a des problèmes
sexuels
qu'est-ce qu'elle se dit faut que
j'aille voir un psy sans même penser que
ça puisse être un problème mécanique ou
bien un problème avec le partenaire
alors justement voici les résultats
d'une expérience pionnière en sexologie
les chercheurs ont séparé les femmes en
deux groupes le groupe à le groupe b les
femmes anneau gastrique du groupe à
elles vont avoir une thérapie on va dire
basique avec des conseils de la
discussion il fane le groupe b elles
elles vont avoir un programme détaillé
sur plusieurs semaines
la masturbation va être corrigée est
guidé par le dialogue
au fil des sens avec le thérapeute on va
leur proposer à elles et à leurs maris
des libres vasseur et on va leur
expliquer concrètement comment est ce
qu'on s'en sert pendant un rapport
le résultat c'est que 90 % des femmes de
ce groupe b réussissent à atteindre
l'orgasme contre seulement 50 % des
femmes de l'autre groupe
90% et elles ont réussi simplement en
changeant leur manière de faire n'est
pas leur manière de penser
donc mme edan s'il vous plaît arrêtez de
penser que s'il ya un problème
c'est dans vos têtes
[Applaudissements]
c'est un réflexe quand tout en grande
partie à cause de notre héritage
religieux mais c'est précisément notre
corps qu'il nous faut nous réapproprier
nous vivons actuellement une époque qui
est exceptionnel car elle nous permet de
questionner de dépasser de surpasser
toutes ces questions toutes ces
oppositions de stéréotypes binaire et
c'est précisément en allant questionner
les fondements de ce dualisme du corps
et de l'esprit
transposé à la polarité hommes femmes
que l'on pourra j'espère arriver une
société plus égalitaire à une société
qui est capable d'intégrer d'accepter
toutes les personnes qui ont le courage
d'assumer des orientations sexuelles qui
défie les clichés qui ont courage de
changer de sexe ou de genre au cours
d'une vie ou de se déclarer asexué long
intersexe parce que dépasser ce dualisme
s'est pas seulement mieux se comprendre
et s'accepter soi-même c'est garantir
aux autres
la liberté d'être et de pouvoir se
regarder et s'accepter comme différent
par rapport à cette norme dépassé ceux
où sortir de ça ou ça c'est refuser les
oppositions c'est sortir des débats
clivants ses phares à pas vers l'autre
et accepter qu'il puisse peut-être à
voir ce bout de la réponse qui nous
manque
sortir du round ce ça où ça s'est passé
dans le mode du et du ca et ça c'est
penser qu'à au moins un endroit
une réunion est possible on peut faire
de la biologie et de la psychologie de
la science et de l'art et au delà du
droit que cela génère ce est
fondamentalement porteurs d'innovation
de création d'invention
par exemple ma double vision de nombreux
scientifiques et de sexologues med au
quotidien dans ma pratique de
thérapeutes
ainsi je vais vous quittez en vous
invitant à vous interroger dans quel
contexte
à quel endroit de votre vie pourriez
vous remplacer ceux où parent et et
qu'est ce que cela pourrait changer
merci
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
[Musique]